こーんにちわ
はじめしゃちょーです。
具体的にはアイスじゃないんですけれども
調べたことがあるんだよ、そう
アイスじゃなくて
あれ、でもこっちはアイスだ
は？
どういうこと？
まあいいや。
とりあえずこちらですね
ガリガリ君ソーダ味
ガリガリ君はアイスではありません。
氷菓っていう氷菓子というくくりになっております
ガリガリ君
世の中には
たくさんのガリガリ君があるよな？
まあ、そんなめちゃくちゃあるわけ
ってわけじゃないですけど
ガリガリ君今まで
様々な種類のガリガリ君が出てたと思うんですけども
俺は
思った
すべてのガリガリ君を一つにまとめた時
どのような味になるかということを
俺はね、心から知りたいと思ったわけですよ
ガリガリ君はね、美味しいんすよ！
言ったらね
ハッ！とホ
なんで今、ハとホっつった？
ほんとに美味しい
暑い時とかに、
ガリガリ君を1本食うだけで
もう一気に体力が回復するわけなんすよ
ね
今売ってる分だけ全種類あつめてみました。
ガリガリ君ソーダ味、巨峰味、
グレープフルーツ、コーラ、リッチミルク。
この世界を探せば、もっとあるのかもしれない。
けど、俺の近くにはこの5種類しか
なかった。
というわけで、今回この5種類を混ぜて
何味になるのかというのをね
ちょっと調べてみようと思います。
純粋な僕のね、あのその、
調べたいっていう気持ちで…
水
純粋な僕の調べたいっていう
僕のその好奇心だけでやってるんで
じゃ、さっそく開けていきましょう
まずはガリガリ君ソーダ味
ｸｯ
巨峰味です
うまい
グレープフルーツ味
知覚過敏こわ
うまい
コーラ味
おいらね、多分ね、コーラ味が一番好きなんすよ
うん。
ﾌﾟｯ
ミルクリッチ味
コーンポタージュとかシチュー味とか
色んな味があるんですけれども
今の季節はミルク味
なんなんだろうなあ
結局このね
氷のねノーマルな安い方が美味しく感じる。
俺はね。
はい、というわけで
こちらのガリガリ君5種類を
合体させて何味になるかというのを
ちょっと確かめてみようと思います。
普通にもう色が綺麗なんすよ
これなんか、こんな綺麗な動画撮るの久しぶりだな
いいよ、はじめいいよ！
綺麗な動画！綺麗な動画になってきたよ
皆もこう、心地よく見れる動画になると思います。
いやー、楽しみですね。綺麗な動画ですね。
こちらの袋にですね
ガリガリ君を1本ずつ入れていきましょう
くそぉ！！！
こちらのガリガリ君、混ぜていきましょう。
おおおおお
おああ
あああ
あぁああ
ああ！
待って、やばい。部屋中がガリガリ君だらけだ。
はい。
というわけで何とか混ぜ終わったんですけども
オッケ！オッケ！
色がこんな感じです今
ここからお前らがどのような色になるかが見所だ
いや凄いな
なんかくまみきさんの髪の毛の色みたいになってきた
なんか凄いね、原宿だねえ
はい。で、ここで
あれ！？
原宿じゃなくなってきた！
やばいぞ！原宿じゃない！
これは、この色は！
京都だ！京都の色になったぞ
待て待て、完全に京都だ
京都の絹織物のような色だ
俺、京都で何度かこのような色を見たことがある
原宿の次のステップは
京都の、絹織物。
俺、疲れてんのかなあ
これはほんとは凍らせて
アイスにすればいいんですけども
現時点でまだ溶けてないので
とって裏返してもまだ落ちることがない
落ちることがないので
まだアイスで、このまま食べれると思います
いただきます！
美味いな
うまいです。
とっても美味しい。
とっても美味しいんだけれども
待て、味の例えがほんとにわからん。
ガリガリ君リッチのミルクですね
このミルクがこの生地となって
その上にコーラ、ソーダ、ぶどう、グレープフルーツ
って乗って
これはね、美味いぞ
フルーティーミルクみたいな
フルーツオレみたいな味だね
美味しい、実に美味しい。
美味しすぎるので今日の動画のオチは特に…
ない